There were deserts on the seafloor Mountains higher than Any peak you'll ever see Up above dry land as I fall I give my body back Hey guys, it's Joel and it's been a minute. I appreciate y'all listening to the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast. It's been a while since I just sat down and recorded an episode like this one where it's just me talking for this mini episode. We've been doing a lot of interviews and that's been really fun.
海底曾有沙漠，山峰比你所见过的任何山巅都要高。当我坠入干涸的陆地，我将身体归还。嘿，大家好，我是乔尔，好久不见。感谢大家收听 Taproot Therapy Collective 播客。我已经很久没有像这样坐下来录制一期只有我一个人说话的迷你剧集了。我们最近做了很多采访，那真的很有趣。
Things have been really crazy and I'm going to give you a quick update before we get into this mini episode. So this was, I wanted to wrap up the cults and conspiracies series, which we lost some guests during that. Things were crazy and we kept hitting scheduling issues and my schedule was not so, wasn't as robust as I wanted, but it's really fun. If you haven't listened to those, I'd go back and check out Matthew Remsky and Julian Walker and John Alelich and see what they have to say about cults and conspiracy theories, because that was a fun series. I wanted to have a sit down with Alice and our other host, James, and have a discussion, but everyone's schedules are all over the place and we didn't get to do that. So I was going to go through those and before I could get around to doing it myself or with them. Um, the episode that we recorded a bit
最近事情非常多，在进入这期迷你剧集之前，我想先给大家做一个简短的更新。我原本想结束“邪教与阴谋论”系列，期间我们失去了一些嘉宾。情况很混乱，我们不断遇到时间安排上的问题，我的日程安排也不像我预期的那样稳固，但这个系列真的很棒。如果你还没听过，我建议你去听听马修·雷姆斯基（Matthew Remsky）、朱利安·沃克（Julian Walker）和约翰·阿莱利奇（John Alelich）的节目，看看他们对邪教和阴谋论的看法，那是一个很有趣的系列。我本想和爱丽丝以及我们的另一位主持人詹姆斯坐下来讨论一下，但大家的日程都排不开，所以没能实现。因此，我打算在自己或与他们一起录制之前，先梳理一下这些内容。嗯，我们之前录制的那期关于阿兹特克形而上学和神话的节目已经发布了。
ago with James Maffey about, um, Aztec metaphysics and mythology, uh, got posted. So this one will be going out after, um, the cult series has already been moved past, but I don't know, man, case or a, so a few updates, my schedule has been, um, crazy and I hope to get back to doing this more regularly. I've kind of had long COVID. I might take breaks, might write more. But we just had some emergencies with the clinic and different things that I had to deal with. Now that we're on the other side of it, we're probably in a better spot. One of them is that the building almost got sold, which would have ended the practice. So, you know, luckily everybody was able to get an LLC and purchase it, which also means that we can have a podcast studio and a place to sit down and do live podcasts with guests, um, or maybe not live, but you know, in person, uh, videos. So we're
所以这一期会在邪教系列结束后发布。但我不知道，伙计，总之，几个更新：我的日程安排一直很疯狂，我希望能恢复更规律的更新。我可能患有长新冠，也许会休息，也许会写更多东西。但诊所遇到了一些紧急情况，我不得不处理各种事情。现在我们已经走出了困境，情况可能好转了。其中一件事是，大楼差点被卖掉，那将导致诊所倒闭。幸运的是，大家能够成立一家有限责任公司并将其买下，这也意味着我们可以拥有一个播客工作室，一个可以坐下来与嘉宾进行现场播客录制的地方，或者也许不是直播，但你知道，是面对面的视频录制。所以我们
not on Google meet all this stuff is probably, you know, I don't know, at least six months away, but it is in the pipeline. Um, if you're one of the listeners who, um, has sent email to me, um, thank you. And please don't, has sent email to me, thank you. And please don't hesitate to reach out about anything. You know, we kind of talk about a lot of stuff, cultural anthropology, the cutting edge of trauma treatment in the future, the past of psychotherapy, the history of that. And then the way that psychology informs like arts, design, cultural movements. You know, you cast a white net and anyone who wants to talk about anything weird, I encourage you to reach out because you may make a great guest for the show.
不用再用 Google Meet 了，这一切可能还需要至少六个月的时间，但已经在筹备中了。嗯，如果你是给我发过邮件的听众之一，谢谢你。请不要犹豫，随时联系我。你知道，我们讨论了很多话题，文化人类学、创伤治疗的前沿、心理治疗的过去和历史，以及心理学如何影响艺术、设计和文化运动。你知道，我们的范围很广，任何想聊点奇怪话题的人，我都鼓励你联系我，因为你可能会成为节目很棒的嘉宾。
I mean, some of the people who've reached out became guests, even though they weren't what they were reaching out to do. If you have an idea for a good guest, send me an email because it's, you know, it's a wide net, but we're still like a little niche. And I make a lot of jokes about, you know, the, it's a wide net, but we're still like a little niche. Um, and I make a lot of jokes about, you know, the clinical psychology one-on-one student, or they take the research one-on-one class, those clinical psychology students. And then so many emails saying I shouldn't have a license. Cause I said something about brain spotting or whatever, uh, or Carl or whatever, you know? Um, and that is very funny. Uh, I, I like, I like to make fun of the, the,
我是说，有些联系我的人后来成了嘉宾，尽管他们最初联系我时并不是为了这个。如果你有好的嘉宾人选，给我发封邮件，因为你知道，虽然范围很广，但我们仍然是一个小众群体。我经常开玩笑说，你知道，那些临床心理学一年级的学生，或者他们修了研究入门课，那些临床心理学学生。然后收到很多邮件说我不应该拥有执照，因为我说了关于脑点疗法（Brainspotting）或者卡尔（Carl）之类的话，你知道吗？那真的很有趣。我喜欢拿我收到的那些糟糕的邮件开玩笑，
the bad emails that I get, but it isn't the majority of them. And if you're listening, if you like it, please rate it. Please write a review if you want to. But really reach out because the point of it is connect with you as somebody who is into these things, not to be a huge show up there with Joe Rogan. There's a lot of things we could do to make the podcast more visible. And we don't because that's not really the goal. The goal is to support people that are kind of in this space and want to talk about this stuff. So that said, thanks. There's been a lot of chaos. Um, I look forward to there being a studio on the horizon, um, where we can sit down and talk about these things, uh, with a bigger cast of people. That's not just me and
但那并不是大多数。如果你在听，如果你喜欢这个节目，请评分。如果你愿意，请写条评论。但一定要联系我，因为节目的意义在于与你这样对这些事物感兴趣的人建立联系，而不是为了成为像乔·罗根（Joe Rogan）那样的大节目。我们可以做很多事情来提高播客的曝光度，但我们没有，因为那不是我们的目标。我们的目标是支持那些处于这个领域并想讨论这些话题的人。话虽如此，谢谢大家。最近有很多混乱。我期待着未来能有一个工作室，在那里我们可以坐下来，与更多的人讨论这些事情，而不仅仅是我一个人，
have more perspective and have some guests in person. I also get, um, excited about getting back to the trauma treatment episodes and some of the stuff that's on the horizon and being able to write a little bit more. I appreciate you. Thank you for being there. Thank you for bearing with us. And I hope you enjoy the cults and conspiracies episodes. So all that said, here's some takeaways from that that I wanted to sit down because all of the guests that we had when we did cults and conspiracy theories had a pretty specific focus and that's great you know but not everybody is kind of synthesizing all the information that i'm trying to synthesize they're talking about their specific um area of expertise because that's what a guest is supposed to do and so to kind of synthesize that
拥有更多的视角，并邀请嘉宾面对面交流。我也很兴奋能回到创伤治疗的剧集，以及一些即将到来的内容，并能多写一点东西。我很感激你们。谢谢你们的支持。谢谢你们的包容。希望你们喜欢“邪教与阴谋论”系列。话虽如此，我想分享一些从中得出的结论，因为我们在做邪教和阴谋论系列时，每一位嘉宾都有非常具体的侧重点，这很好，但并不是每个人都在综合我试图综合的所有信息。他们谈论的是他们特定的专业领域，因为那是嘉宾应该做的。所以为了综合这些内容，
i was hoping i could get um scheduling with alice scheduling with Allison and James because I know that they have some experience with these things. But maybe we can do that later. So the first thing is like I want to make a distinction between a cult and a conspiracy theory. You know, cults are something that or cults are high control groups is a word that you hear used now. There are things that take over and run a huge part of your life and then later replace your identity. I know that these things, there's a Venn diagram. I can hear you already saying in your head, yeah, but conspiracy theories do that too, but let me get through it. Like the cults tend to operate by having, sometimes through a charismatic leader, sometimes through, you know, a teaching or some sort of ritual process of trusting the process.
我本希望能够和爱丽丝以及詹姆斯协调时间，因为我知道他们对这些事情有一些经验。但也许我们以后可以再做。首先，我想区分邪教和阴谋论。你知道，邪教，或者说“高控制群体”，这是现在常用的一个词。它们是一些会接管并掌控你生活很大一部分，然后取代你身份的东西。我知道这些事物之间存在维恩图（重叠），我已经在脑海里听到你在说：“是的，但阴谋论也做同样的事。”但请让我说完。邪教往往通过 charismatic（有魅力的）领导者，或者通过某种教义，或者某种信任过程的仪式来运作。
What they do is they take you and they say, here are all of these things that you need. And then that diagnosis is usually right. If you look at somebody like a Keith Rainier, if you look at somebody like, um, Keith Rainier's of the NXIVM cult, which the documentary, The Vow, and, uh, what's the other one, Seduced? Uh, there may be a third one now, I don't know. Uh, what they're doing is they're going up and they're making a diagnosis. So he goes up to Sarah Edmondson and he says, you're coughing, but you're not sick. And you're doing is they're going up and they're making a diagnosis. So he goes up to Sarah Edmondson and he says, you're coughing, but you're not sick.
他们所做的是把你拉过来，然后说：“这些是你所需要的一切。”而那个诊断通常是正确的。如果你看看像基思·拉尼尔（Keith Raniere）这样的人，如果你看看像 NXIVM 邪教的基思·拉尼尔，纪录片《誓言》（The Vow）和另一部《诱惑》（Seduced）——现在可能还有第三部，我不知道。他们所做的是进行诊断。所以他走到莎拉·埃德蒙森（Sarah Edmondson）面前说：“你在咳嗽，但你并没有生病。你这样做是因为你认为只有生病才能得到关注。没有了这些，你是谁？”这改变了她的人生。因为她觉得：“我一生都在这样做。我爸爸在我生病时会给我关注，或者诸如此类。”我不记得她对自己做的心理分析了，
And you're doing that because you think that you have to be sick to get attention. Who are you without that? And it changes her life. Cause she's like, I've done this my whole life. My dad gave me attention when I was sick or whatever she does. I don't remember her,
但她说基本上是那件事唤醒了她。所以她处于一种脆弱的状态，觉得不知道自己是谁，但她准备好成长了。她看到了阻碍自己的东西。然后基思·拉尼尔说：“好吧，你必须完成这个过程。”你明白，我不会详细讲述整个 NXIVM 的洗脑过程，但诊断是正确的。你知道，有魅力的领导者，邪教，如果它像是一本人们可以投射情感的文本，或者某种模糊的东西，或者有一个过程，它就会留出空间让人们以独特的方式进行这种诊断，因为并不是每个人都在逃避同样的事情。我们都有不同的阴影。所以基思·拉尼尔所做的，以及大多数邪教领袖所能做到的，就是走过来告诉你：“天哪，你有父爱缺失。你有一个父亲形状的空洞。你一生都在试图用毒品填补它。你一直在试图用音乐、其他身份、性或其他东西来填补它。现在你试图让我成为你的父亲，把那种能量投射到我身上，但我不会接受。你需要成为你自己的父亲。”你知道，那个人会说：“哦，哇。”你知道，那个诊断是真实的，对吧？有人可以
um, psychoanalysis of herself, but she says basically that woke her up. So then she's kind of in a vulnerable state where she feels like she doesn't know who she is, but she says basically that woke her up. So then she's kind of in a vulnerable state where she feels like she doesn't know who she is, but she's ready for growth. She sees this thing that's been holding her back. And then Keith Raniere says, okay, you got to do this process. And you understand how, and I'm not going to go through the whole NXIVM indoctrination, but the diagnosis is right. You know, charismatic leaders, cults, if it's like a text or something that people can
诊断出你在逃避什么，你在受苦，而他们仍然可以给出一个完全是胡扯的处方。某种程度上，这就是广告，对吧？你知道，广告不一定是邪教，但它们运作的机制是一样的。就像星巴克在 90 年代说：“嘿，你以为咖啡店就是猫和书之类的吗？不，这是一种新的生活方式。”好吧？如果你更年轻，你根本不知道我在说什么。好吧，因为你不记得星巴克之前的世界是什么样的。嗯，但是苹果电脑，如果你是，你知道，你们有些人可能太年轻而不记得了，但当时的情况是，他们出现在现场说：“这台电脑不像……”我特别指的是他们的广告，
kind of project on or sort of vague or has a process. It's going to leave room for people to do this diagnostic part in a way that is unique to them, because not everyone's running from a different thing. We all have a different shadow. And so what Keith Rainier did and what most cult leaders are able to do is come up and say, oh my gosh, you have a father wound. You have a father shaped hole. And you've been trying to stuff that with drugs your whole life. And you've been trying to stuff that with music and this other identity and sex or whatever. And now you're trying to make me be your father and project that energy on me, but I'm not going to accept it. You need to become your own father, you know, and the person's like, Oh, wow, you know, that diagnosis is real, right? That somebody can
你知道，别给我发邮件说：“嗯，电脑以前并不直观。”史蒂夫·乔布斯想说：“嗯，这是为你大脑准备的自行车，这应该能行。”好吧，我不是在谈论实际产品，我是在谈论它的营销方式。好吧，所以苹果电脑说：“这是一个艺术家在工作室里吹掉他们建造的奇怪东西上的灰尘，他们有这台苹果电脑，他们有这个东西，这里有个人正在进行漫长的旅程，iPad 在皮套里，他是一个定制的绅士，检查他的东西。”他们试图说这些人生活得很有意图，他们生活得很有艺术感，他们拥有极少量非常好的东西，因为那些好东西很贵。嗯，你知道，
diagnose what you're running from, and you're suffering, and they can still have a prescription that is complete bullshit. And sort of that is what advertising is, right? Like, and, you know, and advertising isn't necessarily a cult, but they are operating on that same mechanism, where Starbucks is saying in the 90s, hey, you think a coffee shop is like cat and some books or whatever that isn't, it's a new way of life. Okay? If you're younger, you have no idea what I'm talking about. Okay. Cause you don't remember what a world was before Starbucks. Um, but Apple computer, if you're, you know, you may, some of you may be too young to remember this, but it was like, they came on the scene and they said, this computer is not like, and I'm specifically talking about their advertising,
电脑放在传家宝手表或刀旁边，因为它是一样的东西。它会永远持续下去。并不是说电脑会永远持续下去。但你应该感受到并直觉到这一点。好吧。那种“你想成为一名艺术家”的诊断并不意味着你需要一台苹果电脑。那种“我想进行这次旅程来拥有我生命中的这一部分，我想拥有一种新的生活方式”的诊断，并不意味着你需要一杯星巴克咖啡。邪教、阴谋论、掠夺性治疗、掠夺性宗教中的诊断——你在宗教中也会看到同样的事情。他们会得到那个。我是说，大量的宗教，他们以这些基本上像 70 年代的自助技巧为先导。现在，就像有人告诉我：“嗯，是的，你只是在逃避事情。”
you know, don't send me an email and say, well, computers used to not be intuitive. And Steve jobs wanted to say, well, the, this is a bicycle for your brain this is supposed to work that okay i'm not talking about the actual product i'm talking about the way it was marketed okay so like apple computers said here's an artist blowing dust off an odd thing they built in their studio and they have this apple computer and they have this thing and here's this guy going on this long journey and the ipad's in the leather case and he's a, you know, bespoke gentleman checking his thing that, and they were trying to say these people live intentionally, they live artistically, they have a very small quantity of very nice things because those nice things cost a lot of money. Um, you know, the
你知道，你不知道你的心里有一个黑洞，你正试图用所有这些其他东西来填补它。他们甚至不知道那句话是从哪里来的。你知道，你不知道你的心里有一个黑洞，你正试图用所有这些其他东西来填补它。他们甚至不知道那句话是从哪里来的。你知道，他们的牧师或什么人对他们说了这句话。但那来自 70 年代的人类潜能邪教和辛纳农（Synanon）之类的东西。所以，很多这些东西做出一个诊断，然后告诉你，你必须做点什么才能感觉更好，或者你必须做点什么才能变得完整。好吧。
computer is next to the heirloom watch or knife because it's going to be the same thing. It's going to last forever. It's not computers don't don't last forever. But you're supposed to feel that and intuit that. Okay. And that diagnosis of like, you want to be an artist doesn't mean that you need an apple. That diagnosis of like, I want to go on this thing to have this part of my life. I want to have a new way of life. That doesn't mean that you need a cup of Starbucks coffee. The diagnosis in a cult and a conspiracy theory in predatory therapy, in predatory religion, like you'll see the same thing in religion. They'll get that. I mean, a ton of religions, they lead with this, these basically like self-help techniques from the seventies. Now, like I've had people tell me, well, yeah, you're just running
所以，这就是为什么它被称为邪教，因为在那个点上，那个人正在夺走你的东西，他们正在观察你，让你觉得你正在走向真实。然后他们夺走了你的真实，并用别的东西取代了它。而那个“别的东西”通常会导致对你时间的剥削、对你性欲的剥削、对你的……有时只是对你注意力的剥削。有些人仅仅满足于成为一个自大狂。你知道，很多这种个人崇拜仅仅就是这样，但它用一些对一小群人、一个人或一个团体有利的东西取代了它。然后它会把你置于一个位置，让你去以更小的规模做同样的事情。现在，你不会像创始人那样获得那么多的回报。通常你的回报将是
from stuff. You know, you don't know that you have a black hole in your heart that you're trying to stuff with all this other stuff. They don't even know where that line came from. You know, you don't know that you have a black hole in your heart that you're trying to stuff with all this other stuff. They don't even know where that line came from. You know, their pastor or something said it to them. But like that came from human potential type cults in the 70s and Synanon and things like that. So like a lot of these things make a diagnosis and then they tell you that you have to do something to feel better or you have to do something to be whole. Okay.
自我，但你在实施虐待，而你是一个好人，你认为你感觉很好。所以你所做的是一种虐待。这意味着你没有受到虐待。你明白吗？这就是为什么这么多从这些东西中走出来的人，他们有如此多的问题，因为不仅是如果我承认那个人伤害我足以开始治愈和改变的过程，我必须面对我伤害了所有其他人的羞耻和内疚。所以脆弱性在邪教中总是会被转换和取代。好吧。这就是邪教。邪教和阴谋论的区别，或者我认为“阴谋运动”可能是一个更好的术语，因为有些阴谋论是
So that's what makes it a cult is that in that spot, that person is taking away, they're clocking you, making you feel like you're moving towards authenticity. Then they're taking away your authenticity and they're replacing it with something else. And that something else is this thing that usually leads to exploitation of your time, exploitation of your sexuality, exploitation of your, sometimes it's just your attention that these, some people will settle just for being an egomania. You know, a lot of these kind of cults of personality are just that, but it replaces it with something that is self-serving to a small group of people or a person or a group. And then it's going to put you in a position where you are supposed to go out and do the same thing on a smaller scale. Now, you're not going to get as much of the reward as the founder. Usually your reward is going to be
正确的。对吧。我知道那件事发生了。我只是……术语，因为有些阴谋论是正确的。对吧。我知道那件事发生了。我只是不同意人们用它做的事情。然后还有一些阴谋论是极其疯狂的，根本不是真的。但围绕它们的运动相当主流。所以我不知道理论本身是不是问题所在。我会说“阴谋运动”。对吧。
ego, but you're doing the abuse and you're a good person and you think you feel well. So what you're doing is an abuse. So that means you're not being abused. You get it? And that's why so many people who come out of these things, they have such problems because not only if if I admit that that guy damaged me enough to start the healing and change process, I have to sit with the shame and guilt that I hurt all these other people. And so vulnerability is always going to be switched and replaced in a cult. Okay. That's a cult. The difference in a cult and a conspiracy theory, or I think conspiracy movement might be a better term because there's conspiracy theories that are
所以阴谋，阴谋论与邪教的区别，对吧？是阴谋论，你感觉到一群人正在决定有一个行动方针，因为这就是我不喜欢“理论”的原因之一，是人们坐在一起诊断这件事，谈论它，写书，或者相信它，或者去教堂谈论它，或者去学术界谈论它，或者去学校谈论它，只是在任何地方谈论它，那不是阴谋论，对吧？因为阴谋论涉及行动。现在，行动可能是谈话，对吧？区别在于阴谋论，你已经跨越了那一步，即
right. Right. And I know the thing happened. I just term because there's conspiracy theories that are right. Right. And I know the thing happened. I just don't agree with the thing that people are doing with it. And then there's also conspiracy theories that are wildly insane and are just not real. But the movement around them is like pretty mainstreamed. So I don't know that the theory itself is the problem. I'm going to say conspiracy movement. Right.
你所做的是弥赛亚式的，是重要的，是在反击，是在某种程度上赋予你对抗黑暗势力的力量。现在，邪教不能像阴谋论那样真正赋予你力量，对吧？因为基思·拉尼尔，他需要你一直工作。他需要你的财务、你的性欲和你的一切。就像，你必须很累。你必须精疲力竭。马修·雷姆斯基谈到他所在的其中一个高控制群体时说，他唯一能意识到自己身处邪教的时间是在厨房里，因为他在做东西时能感受到一点点快乐。我是说，他是在为这个组织做奴隶劳动，但那是
So the conspiracy, what a conspiracy theory, how that difference differs from a cult, right? Is that with a conspiracy theory, you are feeling a group of people is deciding that there is a course of action because that's one of the reasons I don't like theory is people sitting around and diagnosing this thing and talking about it and writing books about it or believing it or going to church to talk about it or going to academia to talk about it or school to talk about it and just talking about it anywhere, that isn't a conspiracy theory, right? Because conspiracy theory involves action. Now, the action might be talking, right? The difference is that the conspiracy theory, you've made the leap that
他唯一能感受到自己的地方之一，因为他太累了，无法继续这个过程，它会磨损你。你不能从 NXIVM 下班，然后去搞“匿名者Q”（QAnon）并冲击国会大厦。就像，没有，你没有时间做那个。阴谋运动是采取某种东西并说：“这个行动实际上是赋予力量的。它是好的。它会让你反击，你正在做出改变。”所以我说邪教是给你一种虚假的真实感，对吧？真实的自我。阴谋运动，我知道有一些重叠，但它的主要使命是，它给你一种虚假的代理感。你知道，“他们让青蛙变弯了，他们让孩子变弯了。迪士尼电影被污染了。”你知道，“他们让青蛙变弯了，他们让孩子变弯了，
what you are doing is messianic, is important, is fighting back, is empowering you against the forces of darkness in a way. Now, a cult can't really empower you the same way a conspiracy theory can, right? Because Keith Raniere, he needs you working all of the time. He needs your finances and your sexuality and your whatever. Like, you've got to be tired. You've got to be exhausted. Matthew Rimsky was talking about one of the high control groups he was in, and he was saying that the only time where he had time to realize that he was in a cult was when he's in the kitchen because he just got to feel a little moment of joy while he made something. I mean, he was making it a slave labor for this organization, but it was
迪士尼电影被污染了。”你知道，“没人知道耶稣要回来了。”无论邪教在做什么，它都在说所有这些东西，然后它告诉你，如果你上 Facebook 并发帖，你就是在反击。你处于这个……你可能只是在谈论它，就像我说的，但谈话变成了行动，我们有这个小小的群体泡沫，我们正在传播这个词，它正在增长，它在 4chan 上，你必须出去寻找更年轻的孩子，然后借用他们的风格和文化，把他们带进这个东西里。人们正在觉醒，其他国家的人甚至在支持我们。这感觉就像我正在做一些对我来说有力量的事情。这与其说是我的真实自我被
like one of the only places where he could feel himself because he was so tired of going in the process, it wears you down. You can't clock out of NXIVM and then go do QAnon and Storm the Capitol. Like, there's not, you don't have time to do that. The conspiracy movement is taking something and saying, this action is actually empowering. It is good. It is going to get you to fight back and you're making a difference. So I'd say a cult is giving you a false sense of authenticity, right? Authentic self, a conspiracy movement. And I know there's some overlap, but, but its main mission is, is it's giving you a false sense of agency. You know, they're making the frogs gay. They're making the kids gay. The Disney movies are contaminated. You know, they're making the frogs gay, they're making the kids gay,
一个领导者或团体或高控制系统所取代，而更多的是在告诉我一些……这与其说是我的真实自我被一个领导者或团体或高控制系统所取代，而更多的是在告诉我一些要么效果微乎其微，要么实际上对世界有害的事情。而我自己很棒。你知道，有一个秘密阴谋，在华盛顿特区的那家没有地下室的披萨店里，实际上有一个秘密的孩子地牢。我要去把它扫射了，因为亚历克斯·琼斯（Alex Jones）让我这么做。那是我感到有力量去代表阴谋论采取行动。所以这些事情之间有重叠。它们在技术上是不同的东西。那么它们在哪里相似呢？在因果关系上，我认为它们非常相似。所以这些事情的心理学，
the Disney movies are contaminated, you know, no one knows that Jesus is coming back. Whatever the cult is doing, it's saying all this stuff, and then it's telling you that if you get on Facebook and you post, you're fighting back. You're in this, you may just be talking about it, like I said, but the talk becomes the action, and that we have this little bubble of people, and we're spreading the word, and it's growing, and it's on 4chan and you've got to go out and find younger kids and then co-opt their style and their culture and bring them into this thing. And people are waking up and people in other countries are even supporting us. That feels like I'm doing something that is empowering to me. That's less about my authentic self being replaced
我要休息一下，跳回邪教，对吧？所以邪教和阴谋论中都有大量的多样性。但我认为有一点值得注意，它绝对不是解释为什么每个邪教都存在的理由。但我认为当你观察为什么某种有魅力的领导者和某些宗教，特别是那些具有某种神秘或弥赛亚品质的宗教存在时，它是相关的。所以很多人注意到了一种叫做“盖什温综合征”（Geschwind syndrome）的东西，这基本上是一种癫痫。但患有这种特定形式颞叶癫痫的人有一组症状，如果你看看邪教领袖、神秘主义者、历史上的许多艺术家，不同的人，它并不总是……我是说，这只是一种神经学上的东西。所以它是非道德的。
by a leader or group or a high control system. And it more is telling me something That's less about my authentic self being replaced by a leader or group or a high control system. And it more is telling me something that's either negligibly effective or actually harmful to the world. And myself is great. You know, that there's a secret conspiracy that on this pizza restaurant in DC that doesn't have a basement, um, there's actually a secret dungeon of kids. And I'm going to go shoot that up because Alex Jones told me to. That's me feeling empowered to go act on behalf of as a conspiracy theory. So there's overlap between these things. They are technically different things. So where are they similar? Causationally, I think that they are very similar. So the psychology of these things,
它不是不道德的。它只是非道德的，因为它存在。有时它可以被为了你人格中消极的部分而利用。很多时候有过度宗教化。有一种对精神或道德问题的强烈关注，伴随着宗教幻觉，有时是妄想。还有“书写过多症”（hypergraphia），即你强迫性地书写或绘画。当我与精神分裂症患者一起工作时，我在大约 20% 的人身上看到了这一点。我是说，他们一直在写，我问：“这意味着什么？”他们说：“我必须把它写出来，因为这是
I'm going to take a quick break, jump back to cults, right? So there's a ton of diversity in both cults and conspiracy theories. But one thing that I think is notable, it definitely is not an explanation for why every cult exists. But I think it is relevant when you're looking at why sort of charismatic leaders and certain religious and especially that have a certain quality of a mystical or a messianic quality exist. So there's something that a lot of people have noticed called Gestalt Gershwind syndrome, which is a type of epilepsy, basically. But people who have this particular form of temporal lobe epilepsy have a cluster of symptoms that if you look at cult leaders, mystics, a lot of artists, like different people throughout history, it doesn't always, I mean, it's kind of an, I mean, this is just a neurology thing. So it's amoral.
让你理解的信息。”而那完全是胡说八道。我试图让他们慢下来，把他们拉回到现实中，说：“是的，但你能告诉我你刚才写的东西现在是什么意思吗？”他们会看着它，然后变得非常沮丧，说：“它必须出来。”这不像只是编造。他们无法解释他们刚刚写的东西，但他们仍然必须连续写几个小时。好吧，它绕来绕去。它没有。链接断了。所以现在你不知道它是什么。就像：“等等，我必须回去写。”你问：“等等，你为什么要写？”这是一种妄想性的需求，去创造一些极其重要的东西。
It's not immoral. It's just amoral in that it exists. And sometimes it can be co-opted on behalf of negative parts of your personality. A lot of times there's hyper religiosity. There's this intense focus on spiritual or moral matters that is accompanied by religious visions and sometimes delusions. There's also hypergraphia, which is where you just compulsively write or draw. When I worked with schizophrenia, I saw this in about 20% of people. I mean, they were constantly writing and I was like, what does this mean? And they're like, I have to get it out because this is the
性行为发生了变化，要么是性欲亢进，要么是性欲减退，嗯，或者是一种审美性质的，“我害怕我的性欲，我害怕它和其他人。我将开始在智力上兜圈子，思考为什么所有这些事情实际上是坏的，你不应该做它们。”你知道，嗯，我将开始在智力上兜圈子，思考为什么所有这些事情实际上是坏的，你不应该做它们。你知道，我将想出一个精神上或逻辑上的理由，说明为什么性是堕落的或不纯洁的，等等。所以，我是说，想象一下，如果你是像“天堂之门”邪教中的马歇尔·阿普尔怀特（Marshall Applewhite）那样的人，他是一个压抑的男同性恋者，这对你来说将非常有帮助，不是改变，而是让你加倍投入到你最糟糕的部分，而不是面对它们，因为现在所有的性都是坏的，所以我甚至不需要考虑我的什么，我只需要教别人如何避免你的性欲。
message for you to understand. And it was just total nonsense. And I was trying to slow them down to pull them back into a groundedness and say, yeah, but can you tell me what this thing that you just wrote a minute ago means right now? And they would look at it and they would get so frustrated and be like, it's got to come out. It's not like there was just a confabulation. They couldn't explain the thing that they had just written, but they still had to continue to write for hours. Well, it goes around. It didn't. The link broke. And so now you don't know what it is. And it's like, wait, I just got to get back to writing. And you're like, wait, why are you writing? It is a kind of delusional need to create something incredibly important.
这可能是性欲亢进，就像奥修（Rajneesh）邪教的情况，你知道，在一些有魅力的领导者中有很多这种情况。嗯，还有一种对饮食习惯的痴迷，很多时候这种癫痫也会这样。所以限制饮食、禁食、在特定时间进食，基本上就是仪式。仪式是什么并不重要，暴饮暴食、催吐，就像它是一个仪式。这只是对某种必须以极端方式去做的事情的奇怪痴迷，人类生活的正常部分，创造力、饮食、性、情绪。有一种强迫性和反刍的倾向。还有一种奇怪的无幽默感和清醒，会开关。就像很多这些家伙，当你观察邪教领袖的历史时，你会看到
There's changes in sexual behavior, which is either hypersexuality or just a decreased libido, um, or an aesthetic nature of, I'm afraid of my sexuality and I'm afraid of it and other people. And I'm going to start spinning my wheels intellectually and thinking about why all these things are actually like bad and you shouldn't do them. You know, um, I'm going to start spinning my wheels intellectually and thinking about why all these things are actually like bad and you shouldn't do them. You know, I'm going to come up with either a spiritual or a logical reason why sex is degenerate or impure or whatever. So, I mean, so imagine like if you're somebody like Marshall Applewhite in the Heaven's Gate cult who is a repressed gay man, that is going to be incredibly helpful to you not changing to you doubling down on your worst parts and not confronting them because like now all sex is bad so i don't even need to think about my whatever i need to just teach other people how great it is to avoid your sexuality
他们非常枯燥，他们进行教学，然后继续，然后他们笑了。这对整个群体来说是一个解放的时刻，因为他们有了一个被允许拥有幽默感的时刻。而且，“这难道不好笑吗？”你通过压抑情绪和幽默来关闭群体的“人性”，然后给他们许可去享受它。当你看到很多这些录音带中的那种动态时，如果你看任何这些真实犯罪的东西，就很难不去注意。所以这不是……嗯，还有一种奇怪的……有些人称之为“迂回性”（circumstantiality），但我称之为“螺旋”。有一种语言的螺旋，你在那些可能对苯二氮卓类药物上瘾的人身上看到它，然后仍然在使用它们……嗯，有某种
that could be hypersexuality like in the case of the rajneesh cult you know there there was a lot of that in some of the charismatic leaders um there's also like an obsession with like eating habits a lot of times with this kind of epilepsy. So restricted eating, fasting, eating at certain times, rituals basically. It doesn't matter what the ritual is, binging, purging, like it's a ritual. It's just a strange obsession with how there's a certain way that you have to do that is very extreme, normal parts of human life, creativity, eating, sexuality, emotions. There's an obsessive and a ruminative tendency. There's also strange humorlessness and sobriety that kind of clicks on and off. Like a lot of these guys, when you look at the history of the cult leader, you see
YouTube 哲学类的人以这种方式说话，他们中的很多人……嗯，有某种 YouTube 哲学类的人以这种方式说话，他们中的很多人过去就像“那家伙在吃苯二氮卓”，然后人们说“不，他是天才”，后来发现是的，他确实在吃苯二氮卓。但他们说话的方式就像 JJ·艾布拉姆斯（JJ Abrams）的电影讲故事的方式。就像 JJ·艾布拉姆斯，如果你看过他的东西，场景到场景很引人入胜，让你跟着发生了什么。但你从整部电影中退出来，你会说：“那到底有什么意义？或者他们为什么要那样做？”你被……所吸引，然后你理解了这如何连接到那。但当你想到光，
that they're so dry and they do the teaching and then it goes on and then they laugh. And it's this moment of like liberation for the whole groom because they have this moment where they're allowed to have humor. And, oh, isn't this so funny? And you're turning the humanness of the group off by repressing emotion and humor and then giving them permission to enjoy it. And you'll see when you see that dynamic in a lot of these tapes, if you watch any of these true crime things it's kind of hard to unsee so this is not um there's also like a weird uh some people call it circumstantiality but i call it like a spiral there's like a spiral of language you see it in people that are like addicted to maybe benzos or something and then still using them um like there's certain kind
那是黑暗的对立面。如果我们把光和黑暗放在一起呢？当我们这样做时，我们拥有了一切，还是我们一无所有？如果是一切，嗯，那意味着这里有很多力量。但如果我们什么都没有，那意味着我们没有。好吧。我刚才说的是零。我说“没有”之类的，那是毫无意义的废话。好吧。所以艾伦·瓦茨（Alan Watts）会这样说话，他分享了一些这些特征，他可能更有道理，而且他不是邪教领袖，对吧？就像它对他来说以某种方式起作用了……不像基思·拉尼尔那样。通过基思·拉尼尔，你可以听 50 个小时这些东西，你的结论是它只是
of youtube philosophy people that talk this way and a lot of them um like there's certain kind of youtube philosophy people that talk this way and a lot of them in the past have been like that guy's on benzos and then people are like no he's a genius and then later it turns out yes he is actually on benzos but they kind of talk in the way that a jj abrams movie tells a story like jj abrams if you've ever seen his stuff it's scene to scene's compelling, and it makes you're following what's happening. But you back up from the whole movie and you're like, what was the point of any of that? Or why would they even have done that? You're so compelled by, and then you understand how this connects to that. But when you think of light,
太复杂了，因为你不理解它，实际上你一定很笨，而实际上内容很愚蠢，它没有任何意义。就像很多这些人有这些特征，我不知道拉尼尔是否有这个，但我只是说，当你分析很多邪教的领导层时，寻找这个。所以，嗯，并不是每个人都有盖什温综合征。我想说“格式塔”（Gestalt），因为我是治疗师，是“盖什温综合征”。嗯，我不是那个建立这种联系的人。有很多学术工作对此进行了研究，可以追溯到很久以前。但当你寻找最初的那个人时，
that's the opposite of darkness. What if we put the light and the darkness together? Do we have everything or do we have nothing when that happens? And if it's everything, well, then that means that there's a lot of power over here. But if we have nothing, then that means we have none. Okay. What I just said is zero. I said nothing like that is meaningless nonsense. Okay. So Alan Watts will talk this way and he, he shares some of these features and he has probably more of a point and he's not a call leader right like it was sort of working for him um in a way that like a keith rainier doesn't like by keith rainier you can listen to 50 hours of this stuff and your takeaway is that it's just
因为，你知道，当你观察邪教领袖时，很多事情，对吧？就像妄想、精神……我不认为精神……我不是那种治疗师，我不是弗洛伊德派，我不认为灵性是妄想。我认识很多……当你回到大脑科学时，
so complicated because you don't understand it and actually you must be stupid when really the content is stupid and it doesn't mean anything like a lot of these people have these features and i don't know that rainier had this but but I'm just saying, look for this when you're finding, when you're analyzing the leadership of a lot of cults. So, um, and not everyone has Gestalt. I'm wanting to say Gestalt because I'm a therapist, Gestalt-Geschwin syndrome. Um, and I'm not the one that made that connection. There's a lot of academic, um, work on that that goes back a long ways. But when you're looking for the original person,
我们谈论前脑和子脑，当他们的前脑……他们有一个时刻，他们的子脑关闭了他们的前脑。他们的子脑非常活跃，他们正在告诉我这件事。他们告诉我，他们进入了一个地方，在那里他们看到了与万物的联系。他们对创造有深刻的同理心。他们不像以前那样认同自己的自我。他们仍然想成为一个人，但他们并不真正关心成为一个强大、正确、骄傲或什么样的人。他们只是想变得充满爱、善良并与他人建立联系。
because, you know, a lot of the things when you're looking at the cult leader, right? Like a delusion, spirit, I don't think spirit, I'm not one of those therapists that, I'm not Freudian, I don't think that spirituality is delusional. I know a ton of people who, when you're going back to the brain science,
他们有这种精神体验，你知道，在那个子脑的地方。我并不是说那不是真实的，或者它不是来自某种医学物理的东西。我是治疗师。我不是牧师。当你和他们交谈时，它对他们有效。你知道，他们戒酒了。他们去了那个地方。他们改变了生活。人们认为他们更容易相处。也许他们把工作换成了更充实的工作。它在他们余生中都对他们有效。我认识很多人，那里
we talk about the front brain and the sub brain, where their front, they had a moment where their sub brain turned their front brain turned off. Their sub brain was incredibly active and they're telling me about it. And they're telling me that they went into this place where they saw a connection to all things. They have a profound empathy for creation. They don't identify with their ego as much. They still want to be a person, but they don't really care about being a powerful or right or proud or whatever person. They just want to be loving and good and connected to other people.
发生了这种情况。嗯，我认为这很有趣。嗯，我不知道它来自哪里，但那种灵性，我并不是说它不好，因为它不合逻辑。我不知道它来自哪里，但那种灵性，我并不是说它不好，因为它不合逻辑。我不认为那是对的。但一种妄想，在那里有……你在子脑中有一种超越逻辑的体验，超越了……我认为人们说：“嗯，所有精神层面的人都只是妄想，或者所有精神层面的人都只是软弱，他们试图找到一种让自己变得强大的方法。”这绝对是一种动态。任何说它不会发生的人都是错的。我不认为那是所有灵性背后的原因，在宗教和非宗教环境中与多种类型的人坐在一起，处理宗教大半辈子。我只是……我不认为。但当你看看像艾米·卡尔森（Amy Carlson）纪录片中的那个人，关于艾米·卡尔森的《爱已降临》（Love Has Won）纪录片，她抽着毒品，喝着五分之一瓶的伏特加，说：“嗯，对你们来说，这些是毒品，但对我来说，它们是精神
And they have this spiritual experience, you know, in that sub brain place. And I'm not saying that that isn't real or it doesn't come from a medical physical thing. I'm a therapist. I'm not a priest. And when you talk to them, it's working out for them. You know, they quit drinking. They went to this place. They turned their life around. People think they're easier to deal with. Maybe they changed their job to something that's more fulfilling. It works out for them for the rest of their life. I know a lot of people where that
工具。”她看起来很可怜。他们在拖车里。她周围的人说：“你看不见，但我看见了。她是上帝。我感觉到了。”而她死了。他们仍然在那个邪教里。他们仍然相信这一点。她说会发生的一切都没有发生。
happened. Um, and I think that that is interesting. Um, I don't know where it comes from, but that kind of spirituality, I'm not saying it's bad because it's not logical. I don't know where it comes from, but that kind of spirituality, I'm not saying it's bad because it's not logical. I don't think that's right. But a delusion where there is, and you have an experience in the sub brain that is beyond logic, that is beyond I think people say, well, all spiritual people are just delusional or all spiritual people are just weak and they're trying to find a way to make themselves so powerful. That definitely is a dynamic. Anybody who says it doesn't happen is wrong. I don't think that's behind all spirituality, having sat with multiple types of people in a religious and non-religious setting, dealing with religion for most of my life. I just, I don't. But when you look at somebody like in the Amy Carlson documentary, the Love Has Won documentary about Amy Carlson, she is smoking drugs and drinking fifths of vodka and saying, well, for you, these are drugs, but for me, they're spiritual
那是一种看起来和运作起来像精神体验的妄想。你如何区分它们？嗯，我是说，人们感到沮丧，特别是西方心理学，因为没有一种经验性的方法来做到这一点。你不能给某人做 MMPI（明尼苏达多项人格测验），明尼苏达精神病筛查，你不能给某人……然后让它说：“这个人实际上是一个大师，而这个人是一个江湖骗子，或者这个人有妄想，而这个人有精神体验。”你必须自己对这些事情做过功课，才能获得一种感觉，而且你仍然没有确定性。我认为这就是为什么很多科学家只是说：“嗯，那不是科学。我不会去那里。”这，是的，你是对的。
tools. She looks pitiful. They're in a trailer. And the people around her are saying, you can't see it, but I see it. And she is God. And I feel that. And she's dead. And they're still in that cult. They still believe that. Everything that she said was going to happen didn't happen.
它不是。如果你不想去，你也不必去。但这是很多治疗师以一种无益的方式说“所有灵性都是坏的。它是不合逻辑的。我是开明的无神论者”的另一个原因。或者他们说“所有灵性都是好的。我只是要鼓励每个人都变得‘呜呜’（woo-woo，指迷信或伪科学）。”而在这样做时，你助长了一种妄想。
That is a delusion that is looking and functioning like a spiritual experience. How do you tell those apart? Well, I mean, people get frustrated, especially Western, you know, psychology, because there isn't an empirical way to do it. You can't give somebody the MMPI, the Minnesota Psychiatric Screener, you can't give somebody, you know, a deck floor and then have it say, this person is actually a guru and this person is a charlatan or this person is having a delusion and this person has a spiritual experience. You kind of have to have done your own work with these things to just be able to get a vibe and you still don't have certainty. And I think that is why a lot of scientists just say, well, that's not science. I'm not going to go there, which, yeah, you're right.
好吧？所以当你试图寻找某人时，只要注意他们是如何对待这些体验的。但你知道，那是在这些邪教之下的。我是说，如果你是一个邪教领袖，你想要找到那些有妄想的人，但问题是妄想……这些人并不笨。你知道，约翰·阿莱利奇（John Alelich）刚刚在这方面做了很多工作，她写道，就像，你实际上并不想要一个在邪教中什么都不擅长的人。如果你曾经和像一个有毒的员工一起工作……就像一个被组织纵容的人，但你不喜欢他们，而且他们不应该……
It's not. And you don't have to if you don't want to. But it's another reason why a lot of therapists in a a way that is not helpful, say all spirituality is bad. It's illogical. I'm an enlightened atheist. Or they say all spirituality is good. And I'm just going to encourage everybody to be woo-woo. And in doing that, you enable a delusion.
并不是。如果你不想，你也不必这样做。但这也是为什么许多治疗师以一种无益的方式说所有灵性都是坏事的原因之一。这不合逻辑。我是一个开明的无神论者。或者他们说所有灵性都是好事，并鼓励每个人都去搞那些玄学的东西。这样做，你就是在助长一种妄想。
Okay? So when you're trying to find somebody, just be aware of how they're treating those experiences. But you know, that is underneath these cults. I mean, you're, you're, you're wanting, if you're a cult leader to find the people who are delusional, but the problem is delusions. These people are not stupid. You know, John Alela has just done a lot of work with this, where she writes about how, like, you don't actually want somebody in a cult who's not good at anything. If you've ever worked with like a toxic employee um like somebody who is being enabled by the organization but like you didn't like them and like they weren't they shouldn't
明白吗？所以当你试图寻找某人时，要注意他们是如何对待这些经历的。但你知道，这正是这些邪教背后的东西。我的意思是，如果你是一个邪教领袖，你会想要找到那些有妄想的人，但问题在于妄想。这些人并不笨。你知道，约翰·阿莱拉（John Alela）在这方面做了很多工作，她写道，实际上你并不想要一个在邪教中一无是处的人。如果你曾经和那种有毒的员工一起工作，比如那种被组织纵容但你并不喜欢他们，而且他们本不应该那样的人
be there and they made everyone was like doing their job for them if you had a cult full of those people it wouldn't work but really those people are generally pretty like easy to get them to join cults right the cult is keeping those people out. Because what the cult wants to do is apply those in the world, which is why cults get worse when there's less pathways to economic, spiritual, psychological fulfillment in society. Cults get worse because it's easier for these people to be found. Or the person already is doing that and you want to convince them that they're doing it wrong. They're doing it the right way. Really, they have to do it through you. You want to get those people. Look at these
在那里，他们让每个人都像是在为他们工作。如果你有一个全是这类人的邪教，那是不行的，但实际上这些人通常很容易被诱导加入邪教，对吧？邪教正是把这些人拒之门外。因为邪教想要做的是在世界上应用这些东西，这就是为什么当社会中缺乏经济、精神和心理满足的途径时，邪教就会变得更糟。邪教变得更糟是因为这些人更容易被找到。或者那个人已经在做这件事了，而你想说服他们做错了。他们做的是对的。实际上，他们必须通过你来做。你想抓住这些人。看看这些
documentaries. Look at some, like these people are film directors. I mean, yes, the movies that Mark Vincente or whatever directed before he joined NXIVM were, we will BS on the half of another cult, but like he was effective at stuff. You know, Sarah Edmondson was running a business. Nikki Klein was an actress. I mean, these people were successful. Keith Renier wasn't going into homeless shelters, not that homeless people are not smart or that homeless people are not, you know, capable. It's just that you're looking for people who either have the, you're looking for people who have the ability to be effective tomorrow with your help or who are already effective because at the end of the day, a cult is a business. If it's not making money, if it's not making extra labor for you to exploit, then you're not able to get anything out of it. So why would you run it? You know, um, nobody works for free, not even a cult leader. So except the, I guess the people in the cult work for free. So you're looking for people who are not stupid, who are not, not emotionally intelligent, who are not, um, a lot of these
纪录片。看看一些，比如这些人是电影导演。我的意思是，是的，马克·文森特（Mark Vincente）或其他人在加入NXIVM之前导演的电影，我们会在另一个邪教的半边天里胡说八道，但他确实在某些方面很有效率。你知道，莎拉·埃德蒙森（Sarah Edmondson）在经营一家企业。尼基·克莱恩（Nikki Klein）是一位女演员。我的意思是，这些人很成功。基思·雷尼尔（Keith Renier）并没有去无家可归者收容所，并不是说无家可归者不聪明，或者无家可归者没有能力。只是你在寻找那些要么有能力在你的帮助下明天就能发挥作用的人，要么是已经发挥作用的人，因为归根结底，邪教就是一门生意。如果它不赚钱，如果它不能为你创造额外的劳动力来剥削，那么你就无法从中得到任何东西。那你为什么要经营它呢？你知道，嗯，没有人免费工作，即使是邪教领袖也不例外。所以，我想邪教里的人是免费工作的。所以你在寻找那些不愚蠢、不缺乏情商、不……很多这些
people aren't woo woo. They end up in a woo woo cult because they're so disconnected from their spirituality that when someone opens that door and says, look what spirituality can feel like, and you're so hungry for that, then you, you know, these places converted scientists and doctors for that reason. I think, you know, nobody showed them how to do that in a healthy way or open the door for them to do it themselves. So, um, going back to conspiracy theories and some of the overlap, one way to think about a conspiracy theory is that it is a metaphor for something that like you already know is true, but you don't know how it's true. And so, for example, like, I remember there were all these things, you know, I'm older, like in the 90s, you saw, you know, everything was going pretty good. Like, people like Clinton, largely, some people were angry
人并不是那种神神叨叨的人。他们最终进入一个神神叨叨的邪教，是因为他们与自己的灵性脱节太久了，当有人打开那扇门说，看看灵性可以是什么感觉时，你对此如此渴望，那么你，你知道，这些地方因为这个原因转化了科学家和医生。我想，你知道，没有人向他们展示如何以健康的方式做到这一点，或者为他们打开门让他们自己去做。所以，嗯，回到阴谋论和一些重叠部分，思考阴谋论的一种方式是，它是一个隐喻，代表着你已经知道是真的，但你不知道它是如何成为真的东西。所以，例如，我记得有所有这些事情，你知道，我年纪大了，比如在90年代，你看到，你知道，一切都进行得相当顺利。比如，人们很大程度上喜欢克林顿，有些人对他感到愤怒
about him, his values or something, but they still couldn't complain about the economy because it was everyone was doing pretty well and so people were like trying you know they're like it was a time of kind of economic surplus or whatever and i remember like my parents are boomers and they never said anything about this but you just saw it through like movies or news or you know the stuff that was on the things that i read that i probably shouldn't read when I was a kid. Um, it was like boomers would talk about, there were all these things that probably never happened. Like they probably weren't real. Um, or like most things like that, somebody did it like once in New York and then like
关于他的价值观或其他什么，但他们仍然不能抱怨经济，因为每个人都做得很好，所以人们就像试图，你知道，他们就像那是一个经济过剩的时代，或者其他什么，我记得，比如我的父母是婴儿潮一代，他们从来没有说过关于这个的任何事情，但你只是通过电影或新闻，或者你知道，我读的东西，我小时候可能不应该读的东西看到了它。嗯，就像婴儿潮一代会谈论，有所有这些可能从未发生过的事情。比如它们可能不是真的。嗯，或者像大多数这样的事情，有人在纽约做过一次，然后就像
wrote a story about it. And then other people read it and were like, Oh, this is coming to the suburbs, you know, but things like key parties, which was this like urban legend kind of, again, a lot of overlap between urban legends and conspiracy theories that you would just go to a party or somebody knew somebody because everyone was doing this where you just like you were going to a party and you thought it was a normal dinner party and you were going with your partner and then they told you, oh, you have to put your key in this bowl and actually everyone at this party is going to get someone else's keys and they have to have sex with that person. You know, like you would never accidentally walk into an orgy, like,
写了一个关于它的故事。然后其他人读了它，就像，哦，这要传到郊区了，你知道，但像换妻派对（key parties）这样的事情，这就像都市传说一样，同样，都市传说和阴谋论之间有很多重叠，你只是去参加一个派对，或者有人认识某人，因为每个人都在这样做，你只是去参加一个派对，你以为这是一个正常的晚餐派对，你和你的伴侣一起去，然后他们告诉你，哦，你必须把你的钥匙放在这个碗里，实际上这个派对上的每个人都要拿到别人的钥匙，他们必须和那个人发生性关系。你知道，就像你永远不会意外地走进一场狂欢派对，就像，
especially not in 1990s America like that. If you want to do that, that's fine. But it's just I am and I don't have any personal experience with this. But I imagine that like, planning an orgy with a bunch of people from your church is probably a lot of work. There's probably a lot of ground work and conversations that you have to have, you know, but there is this feeling that like something wasn't right or there was something about the civilization that they weren't understanding or they weren't getting. A lot of news from that 90s period was like targeted at this thing that the internet is coming. Yeah, AOL CDs are getting mailed to your house and this thing beeps and boops and it lets you send an email. And it's kind of lame, but it's going to change everything. And this we're on the edge of this, you know, like we were at this point where the world, the rug was about to get pulled out from under everybody and everybody kind of felt
特别是在1990年代的美国，不是那样的。如果你想那样做，那没问题。但这只是我，我对此没有任何个人经验。但我认为，和一群来自你教会的人计划一场狂欢派对可能需要做很多工作。可能需要做很多基础工作和对话，你知道，但有一种感觉，就像有些事情不对劲，或者关于文明有些他们不理解或没有得到的东西。那个90年代时期的很多新闻都是针对互联网即将到来这件事的。是的，AOL光盘被寄到你家，这个东西发出哔哔声，让你发送电子邮件。这有点蹩脚，但它会改变一切。我们正处于这个边缘，你知道，就像我们正处于这一点，世界，地毯即将从每个人脚下被抽走，每个人都有点感觉到
that. And they felt like they were going to be going through this routine where there was this normal thing that they were doing. And then all of a sudden they didn't understand how the world worked. They didn't understand what the rules were. Their life was not going to look like their parents' life, even though they thought that it, and that was true. That was going to happen. And their intuition there was not wrong. But so much of that, I don't want to just talk about the 90s, that could be a whole episode, but like so much of that culture was anticipating this sea change that was going to make everything different in a way that would never go back to being normal. Some things like that you can predict, right? Like the internet, you know, there were that we knew
到了。他们觉得他们将经历这个例行公事，他们正在做一件正常的事情。然后突然之间，他们不明白世界是如何运作的。他们不明白规则是什么。他们的生活看起来不会像他们父母的生活，尽管他们认为会，而那是真的。那将会发生。他们的直觉并没有错。但其中很多，我不想只谈论90年代，那可能是一整集的内容，但那种文化中有太多东西在预见这种海啸般的变化，这将使一切变得不同，以至于永远无法回到正常状态。有些事情你可以预测，对吧？比如互联网，你知道，我们知道
that this was going to happen. We knew that it was going to change. We didn't know how, but we knew that we wouldn't be the same. Other cultural things that set things off like 9-11 or the atom bomb, like you can't really predict, like technology just gets to this point or a cultural event happens. And it wasn't something that everyone could feel with their intuition was right on the edge of the horizon, but the internet did work like that. And so you go to something like a key party that you're going to go to the normalest, most safe thing that you've ever done, like go eat dinner with the people in your church. And then all of a sudden you're going to be in an orgy or some kind of sexual affair, whatever, something that just so contradicted your values that really everybody was going to see inside of what
这将会发生。我们知道它会改变。我们不知道如何改变，但我们知道我们不会保持原样。其他引发事情的文化事件，比如9-11或原子弹，你无法真正预测，比如技术只是达到了这一点，或者发生了文化事件。这不是每个人都能用直觉感觉到就在地平线边缘的事情，但互联网确实是那样运作的。所以你去参加像换妻派对这样的事情，你以为你要去参加你做过的最正常、最安全的事情，比如和教会里的人一起吃晚饭。然后突然之间，你就要参加一场狂欢派对或某种性丑闻，无论什么，某种与你的价值观如此矛盾的事情，真的每个人都会看到每个人内心深处
everyone wanted in a way that they didn't want to see. I mean, I mean, the internet did kind of do that. It kind of key partied everybody. We had to, we had to hear what our family members actually thought in a way that just talking to them didn't get us to, you know, you had to give them the anonymity to sort of tell them themselves or something. Um, so I don't want to waste too much time like with that metaphor, but I think that like a conspiracy theory does that, you know, the anonymity to sort of tell them themselves or something. So I don't want to waste too much time with that metaphor. But I think that like a conspiracy theory does that, you know, Matthew Rimsky, when we did the interview, like he's talking about how when people are like, they know that the CIA overthrows these places in America, and then it's not on American news. They know that Jeffrey Epstein was not just a financier in New York who all of a sudden got 10 sweetheart deals for no
想要的东西，以一种他们不想看到的方式。我的意思是，我的意思是，互联网确实做到了这一点。它确实让每个人都参加了换妻派对。我们不得不听到我们的家人实际上在想什么，以一种仅仅和他们交谈无法让我们做到的方式，你知道，你必须给他们匿名性，让他们自己说出来或者其他什么。嗯，所以我不想在那个隐喻上浪费太多时间，但我认为阴谋论确实做到了这一点，你知道，匿名性让他们自己说出来或者其他什么。所以我不想在那个隐喻上浪费太多时间。但我认为阴谋论确实做到了这一点，你知道，马修·里姆斯基（Matthew Rimsky），当我们做采访时，他谈到当人们像，他们知道中央情报局在这些地方推翻了美国，然后它不在美国新闻上。他们知道杰弗里·爱泼斯坦（Jeffrey Epstein）不仅仅是纽约的一位金融家，他突然得到了10笔甜头交易，没有任何
reason and then hung himself. They know that these things aren't real, that there are forces at work that we don't know. One of the authors who, I heard him in an interview and I don't remember the book that he wrote, but what he was saying about his jump for staying sane while he wrote all of these things about conspiracy theories and said, Hey, look, probably all this stuff happened because look, you've got 90 coincidences here that are so coincidental. A lot of them are probably true, but I can't tell you definitively than any of them are, but I can tell you that there's probably some smoke. There's probably some fire under the smoke because even if half the stuff is wrong, it's still pretty damning. He was saying you have to have that attitude because when you make the jump between this is extremely likely based on all the information that we have to, I know this is what happened. You can't know that you have to
理由，然后上吊自杀了。他们知道这些事情不是真的，有我们不知道的力量在起作用。其中一位作者，我在一次采访中听过他，我不记得他写的书了，但他关于他在写所有这些关于阴谋论的事情时如何保持理智的跳跃所说的是，嘿，看，可能所有这些事情都发生了，因为看，你有90个巧合在这里，它们是如此巧合。其中很多可能是真的，但我不能明确地告诉你其中任何一个是真的，但我可以告诉你，可能有一些烟雾。烟雾下可能有一些火，因为即使一半的事情是错的，它仍然相当令人震惊。他说你必须有那种态度，因为当你做出跳跃时，从基于我们拥有的所有信息这极有可能，到我知道这就是发生的事情。你不能知道，你必须
know that you can't know that you have to know that you can look at all this disclassified things that this person is released from jail over and over and over again by the men in black suits, that this thing is thrown out, that this doesn't happen to anybody else. But you can look at all this disclassified things that this person is released from jail over and over and over again by the men in black suits that this thing is thrown out that this doesn't happen to anybody else but you can't say but I know that the CIA did it because this is right when Thaksin was coming in and then he
知道你不能知道，你必须知道你可以看看所有这些解密的东西，这个人被黑衣人一次又一次地从监狱里释放出来，这件事被抛弃了，这不会发生在任何人身上。但你可以看看所有这些解密的东西，这个人被黑衣人一次又一次地从监狱里释放出来，这件事被抛弃了，这不会发生在任何人身上，但你不能说，但我知道中央情报局做了这件事，因为这正是他信（Thaksin）进来的时候，然后他
took over so he must have put these people in that's where you've joined the conspiracy theory because you can't know those things you can be pretty sure that something like that happened but it is the certainty that makes you the convert. And that's how he said he stayed a researcher instead of a convert. One of the other things that I've heard, I've heard this account from several people who write
接管了，所以他一定把这些人放进去了，这就是你加入阴谋论的地方，因为你无法知道那些事情。你可以相当确定发生了类似的事情，但正是这种确定性让你成为了皈依者。这就是他说他保持研究者身份而不是皈依者身份的方式。我听到的另一件事，我从几个写
books about conspiracy theories. So I think they probably talked to the same guy who's spoken anonymously. I don't know who it is, but what they said is this guy who evidently was a politician, a successful one who spoke off the record is he said, you have to understand that most of the people who were in the conspiracy theory aren't really in it. That the people who actually are going to Epstein Island are doing a thing like they're always going to be the minority, but what they're, what the, the, these organizations are going to do or what wealth and power is going to, going to do to vet you is they're going to put you minority. But what these organizations are going to do or what wealth and power is going to do to vet you is they're going to put you in a situation where you're uncompromising, where you see this thing and you know someone else is doing something bad
关于阴谋论书籍的人那里听到了这个说法。所以我认为他们可能和同一个匿名发言的人谈过。我不知道他是谁，但他们所说的是，这个显然是政治家的人，一个成功的、私下发言的人，他说，你必须明白，大多数参与阴谋论的人并没有真正参与其中。那些真正去爱泼斯坦岛的人正在做一件事，就像他们总是少数，但这些组织要做的是，或者财富和权力要做的是审查你，他们会把你放在少数。但这些组织要做的是，或者财富和权力要做的是审查你，他们会把你放在一个你无法妥协的情况下，在那里你看到这件事，你知道别人在做坏事
and everyone knows that you saw it and everyone knows that you know. And if you ever talk about it, you're ostracized, you're out, your career is over. But you didn't do it. You don't have to do it. You don't have to do it. You don't have to do the bad thing, but you do have to be around it and you have to let everyone know that you know that. And in that way, you're complicit. You're complicit because you know that if you say something, you're cut out. And so your whole career is not saying something. I think that's really interesting when you get into political conspiracy theories and this is not about the adherence, the converts who get into them. This is about the reason that they actually exist, the systems that enable them
每个人都知道你看到了，每个人都知道你知道。如果你谈论它，你就会被排斥，你出局了，你的职业生涯就结束了。但你没有做。你不必做。你不必做。你不必做坏事，但你必须在它周围，你必须让每个人都知道你知道这一点。通过这种方式，你是同谋。你是同谋，因为你知道如果你说了什么，你就会被切断。所以你的整个职业生涯就是不说任何话。我认为当你进入政治阴谋论时，这非常有趣，这与追随者、进入其中的皈依者无关。这是关于它们实际存在的原因，使它们成为可能的系统
and wealth and power. Um, you know, multiple people wrote books about, you know, Epstein and, and, um, you know, Charles Manson's connection with, um, federal Intel and different things. And they were all kind of interviewing a politician at the end of his life who, you know, evidently their research led them to this person. And that was something that he said. Um, but the thing that I think is interesting there is that certainty that you can never not know. And so most people are not researching that academically. They don't know half the information that any of these guys do. They're just looking at it and it feels right.
以及财富和权力。嗯，你知道，多个人写了关于，你知道，爱泼斯坦，以及，嗯，你知道，查尔斯·曼森（Charles Manson）与，嗯，联邦情报局和不同事情的联系。他们都在采访一位生命尽头的政治家，你知道，显然他们的研究引导他们找到了这个人。这就是他所说的一些事情。嗯，但我认为那里有趣的是那种你永远无法不知道的确定性。所以大多数人并没有在学术上研究它。他们不知道这些人中的任何一个所知道的一半信息。他们只是看着它，感觉它是对的。
If you're old, if you don't have experience with people different from you, and you're watching TV and the world is changing and you don't like what's changing, and somebody says, hey, the president is actually a Muslim. The president is actually an alien. The president is actually part of a group of people from another country that are coming here to hurt you. And you see problems in the world, and you feel like something's wrong. And then somebody tells you, this is what's wrong wrong in a way that speaks to what you're seeing, validates it, and it sounds right to you based on your cultural biases, then you're just going to be certain that that thing is real. That is how most people think. And we can sit back and say, oh, well, I don't think that way. But there's a lot of things that are, I try not to talk about
如果你老了，如果你没有与你不同的人打交道的经验，你在看电视，世界正在改变，你不喜欢正在改变的东西，有人说，嘿，总统实际上是穆斯林。总统实际上是外星人。总统实际上是来自另一个国家的一群人的一部分，他们来这里是为了伤害你。你看到了世界上的问题，你觉得有些不对劲。然后有人告诉你，这就是错的地方，以一种符合你所看到的方式，验证它，并且基于你的文化偏见听起来是对的，那么你就会确信那件事是真的。这就是大多数人的思考方式。我们可以坐下来，说，哦，好吧，我不那样想。但有很多事情是，我尽量不谈论
politics on the show, but where I can't get away from talking about politics is psychology is real. And a whole lot of these, um, takes on things presuppose that it's not okay. So like there are certain things that are psychological inevitabilities. And so if something is a psychological inevitability and you say, well, it's my political position that, that, that that that isn't inevitable, I'm sorry, I guess that I'm being political there. Because when you have no pathway in society to self-actualization, when you have no pathway to, and there's a lot of things that are part of that, economic stability, education, access to healthcare, a belief that the future is going to be slightly better, and in the worst case, not that much worse than the present. When you, you know, a way to actualize your goals, your potential, when you don't have that, it is inevitable that you will start having conspiracy theories.
节目中的政治，但我无法回避谈论政治的地方是心理学是真实的。而这些对事物的看法中有很多预设了它是不对的。所以，比如有一些心理上的必然性。所以如果某事是心理上的必然性，而你说，好吧，我的政治立场是，那不是必然的，我很抱歉，我想我在那里变得政治化了。因为当你没有社会途径来实现自我实现时，当你没有途径去，而且有很多事情是其中的一部分，经济稳定、教育、获得医疗保健、相信未来会稍微好一点，在最坏的情况下，不会比现在差太多。当你，你知道，一种实现你的目标、你的潜力的方式，当你没有这些时，你必然会开始有阴谋论。
It is inevitable that you will start having cults. This goes back like to every empire on earth. Like you can go back to the Roman empire when it's not doing so on. And people are able to look at, you know, earlier generations were like, we're conquering all this stuff. The gall is getting paraded through the street. Um, they're bringing in elephants and these animals that I've never even seen before and saying, we conquered these countries. Um, there's all this stuff that you're getting, you're getting the bread card and it's, it's great.
你必然会开始有邪教。这可以追溯到地球上的每一个帝国。比如你可以追溯到罗马帝国，当它表现不佳时。人们能够看到，你知道，前几代人就像，我们正在征服所有这些东西。高卢人正在街上游行。嗯，他们带来了大象和这些我以前从未见过的动物，并说，我们征服了这些国家。嗯，你正在得到所有这些东西，你正在得到面包卡，它，它很棒。
You know, you're, it's successful. And then the empire starts to decline. And so they say, okay, well, here's the football game. Watch this to be entertained and get your libidinal rage out. But don't think about how like, you're not actually getting what you want. Go to the gladiatorial thing and cheer on your team or watch whatever. I mean, they, they invest in the gladiatorial stuff.amed us when they want to distract you from the crumbling empire that is making your quality of life worse that only works for so long i mean it is a psychological
你知道，你，它是成功的。然后帝国开始衰落。所以他们说，好吧，这是足球比赛。看这个来娱乐，把你的力比多愤怒发泄出来。但不要考虑你，你实际上并没有得到你想要的。去参加角斗士比赛，为你的球队欢呼，或者看别的什么。我的意思是，他们，他们投资于角斗士的东西。当我们想让你从正在使你的生活质量变差的崩溃帝国中分心时，这只会奏效一段时间，我的意思是这是一种心理
inevitability that you're going to get something like mithroth the cult of mithroth in the army you know an army cult is going to be scary because when your whole army converts to a religion at a certain point are they going to do what the emperor tells them to do? You know, um, you're going to get things because when I don't have actual active power out here, then what happens is I'm going to, unless I just say I give up, I'm going to jump off a bridge. There's no point in my life, which that person, you know, politically, I guess, ceases to matter after that point. Just it's sad. I'm not saying they don't matter, but I'm saying that they're no longer affecting the political process.
必然性，你会得到像密特拉教（Mithroth）这样的东西，军队里的密特拉教。你知道，军队邪教是可怕的，因为当你的整个军队在某个时候皈依了一种宗教时，他们会做皇帝告诉他们做的事吗？你知道，嗯，你会得到这些东西，因为当我在这里没有实际的积极权力时，那么发生的事情是，除非我只是说我放弃，否则我会从桥上跳下去。我的生活没有意义，那个人，你知道，在政治上，我想，在那之后就不重要了。只是很悲伤。我不是说他们不重要，但我是说他们不再影响政治进程了。
If you check out from society and go off into the woods, um, then what happens is I move inward and I start to find mysticism, esotericism, you know, all the people who get bullied in high school, like those people are going to go, you know, inward and play D and D or be an actor, do something that involves masking and ritual and, um, uh, accessing and mapping parts of my internal self. And those aren't bad things to do, but when you have no power that is effective, available to people actively, when they know that if I can vote right or vote left or go up or go down, it doesn't matter if I can vote right or vote left, or go up or go down, it doesn't matter, I'm going to get the same result, the political process doesn't really reflect my ego, my interests, then they look for that power personally. And
如果你从社会中退出，走进森林，嗯，那么发生的事情是我向内移动，我开始寻找神秘主义、深奥主义，你知道，所有在高中被欺负的人，比如那些人会去，你知道，向内，玩龙与地下城（D&D）或者成为演员，做一些涉及伪装和仪式的事情，嗯，呃，访问和映射我内在自我的部分。这些并不是坏事，但当你没有对人们积极有效、可用的权力时，当他们知道如果我能投右票或投左票，或者向上或向下，这没关系，如果我能投右票或投左票，或者向上或向下，这没关系，我会得到同样的结果，政治进程并没有真正反映我的自我、我的利益，那么他们就会亲自寻找那种权力。而
sometimes that leads to people who become cool artists and write cool stuff. But as a inevitability, you're going to get cults and conspiracy theories because people are going to say, one, I'm going to go to a cult leader who says, this is how you feel better. This is how you do it, right? I'm telling you why you feel bad. Just statistically, that's going to happen more. You're also going to have people who find a conspiracy theory and say, this system makes me meaningful and powerful and gives me action. Posting on the internet, going to this rally, sharing this information, fighting back. I mean, you get that language in the conspiracy theory in a way you don't get in the cult. I mean, the cult is saying, we're going to tell you what to do. You don't need to figure it out. The conspiracy theory is like helping you infer what gives you agency. So I don't know. I hope that that's helpful. I hope that that's an
有时这会导致人们成为酷艺术家并写出酷的东西。但作为一种必然性，你会得到邪教和阴谋论，因为人们会说，第一，我要去一个邪教领袖那里，他说，这就是你感觉更好的方式。这就是你做对的方式，我告诉你为什么你感觉不好。从统计学上讲，这种情况会发生得更多。你也会有发现阴谋论的人，并说，这个系统使我有意义和强大，并给了我行动。在互联网上发帖，参加这个集会，分享这个信息，反击。我的意思是，你在阴谋论中得到了那种语言，而你在邪教中没有得到。我的意思是，邪教在说，我们要告诉你做什么。你不需要弄清楚。阴谋论就像帮助你推断什么给了你代理权。所以我不知道。我希望这有帮助。我希望这是一个
interesting summary. I'm trying to think if there's any part of that that I didn't get to. Some of those are rabbit holes that I could have gone down longer. But I think all of those things are things that were touched on the cults and conspiracy theories podcast. If you're interested in that, I'm just kind of giving you a lot of different, uh, bullet points that you may want to look at more. Um, I definitely think that there is a pretty profound, um, and some people don't like it when I use the more Jungian language on the show, but I do think it's useful. Um, we all have intuition and when we're cut off from intuition,
有趣的总结。我正在尝试思考是否有任何我没有涉及的部分。其中一些是我可以深入研究更长时间的兔子洞。但我认为所有这些事情都是在邪教和阴谋论播客中触及的事情。如果你对此感兴趣，我只是给你很多不同的，呃，要点，你可能想更多地看看。嗯，我绝对认为有一个相当深刻的，嗯，有些人不喜欢我在节目中使用更多的荣格语言，但我确实认为它很有用。嗯，我们都有直觉，当我们与直觉切断联系时，
things get, you know, pretty dark, they get they get pretty sad, we may look like we're a successful doctor, lawyer, wealthy person, like doing whatever. But we don't feel like we're able to be in touch with the part of our brain that is more than logic that is more than language that is more than time. And so that saying of like, if you don't have a religion, then something will become your religion, that, you know, I remember hearing a bunch of people say that in the 70s. I went alive in the 70s, but in what I'm reading and watching things, so I don't know who exactly said that. But I mean, that's what it's saying is that if you don't make your intuitive function conscious, then it will remain unconscious and that unconsciousness
事情变得，你知道，相当黑暗，它们变得相当悲伤，我们看起来可能像是一个成功的医生、律师、富有的人，比如做任何事情。但我们不觉得我们能够接触到我们大脑中不仅仅是逻辑、不仅仅是语言、不仅仅是时间的那部分。所以那句名言，如果你没有宗教，那么某事就会成为你的宗教，那，你知道，我记得在70年代听到很多人这么说。我70年代还活着，但在我阅读和观看的东西中，所以我不知道确切是谁说的。但我的意思是，这就是它所说的，如果你不让你的直觉功能有意识，那么它将保持无意识，而那种无意识
will control you. So a lot of the people that are in these, no one ever said, I mean, remember the diagnosis of the cult leaders, right? No one ever said, hey, look, you don't have to be sick to be important. You are important. You don't have to, you are an effective actor. You don't have to make movies on behalf of this other, or your director, writer, you know, you don't have to make movies on behalf of this other person's religious thing. You can find a point within yourself that you want to tell, that you want to say. You know, all of these things that get worse when you have a civilization basically that is cutting off past actualization and it's not functioning, people statistically will just hear less and then people
会控制你。所以很多在这些里面的人，没有人说过，我的意思是，记住对邪教领袖的诊断，对吧？没有人说过，嘿，看，你不必生病才能变得重要。你很重要。你不必，你是一个有效的行动者。你不必代表这个其他人制作电影，或者你的导演、作家，你知道，你不必代表这个其他人的宗教事物制作电影。你可以在你自己内心找到一个你想讲述的、你想说的点。你知道，所有这些在当你有一个基本上切断了过去实现并且没有运作的文明时变得更糟的事情，人们在统计学上只会听得更少，然后人们
will um get worse they'll be more susceptible to these things so you hear cult used kind of too much like i think a lot of times um remember when we're talking about cults here you know a conspiracy theory is a metaphor that describes a reality with a metaphor where we can't see reality clearly. We don't really know what is actually happening under the hood. And so we make this guess and then we become too certain about that guess. Whereas a cult is something that is replacing a part of you with something that feels easier or more authentic. But ultimately, there's going to be this bait and switch where that thing is going to control you and it's going to cut you off from authenticity so that you're trapped. That is how they're going to function. So when you see people
会嗯变得更糟，他们会更容易受到这些事情的影响。所以你听到邪教被用得有点太多了，就像我认为很多时候，嗯，记住当我们在这里谈论邪教时，你知道，阴谋论是一个隐喻，用一个隐喻描述现实，我们无法清楚地看到现实。我们真的不知道引擎盖下实际上发生了什么。所以我们做出这个猜测，然后我们对那个猜测变得太确定了。而邪教是某种正在用感觉更容易或更真实的东西取代你的一部分的东西。但最终，会有这种诱饵和转换，那个东西会控制你，它会切断你的真实性，这样你就被困住了。这就是它们运作的方式。所以当你看到人们
say, well, this political party is a cult or that both political parties are cults or, you know, this, the entire religion of this as a cult or something, I have a problem with that kind of language because I don't think, um, cults can quite be that big, you know, like are most Americans affiliated with some organization somewhere that they don't understand how it works and it exploits them. Yes. Like, you know, almost definitely. Um, but you know, what is that? That's a problem that needs to change, but that's the, that's the problem driving the cult. You know, it isn't really the cult. It isn't really a conspiracy theory. It is the system not working as intended. And there is an inevitability that I want to leave you with, where when two parties offer
说，好吧，这个政党是一个邪教，或者两个政党都是邪教，或者，你知道，这个，整个宗教作为一个邪教或什么，我对那种语言有问题，因为我不认为，嗯，邪教可以那么大，你知道，比如大多数美国人是否隶属于某个地方的某个组织，他们不明白它是如何运作的，它剥削他们。是的。就像，你知道，几乎肯定。嗯，但你知道，那是什么？那是一个需要改变的问题，但那是驱动邪教的问题。你知道，它并不是真正的邪教。它并不是真正的阴谋论。它是系统没有按预期运作。并且有一种必然性我想留给你，当两个政党提供
you no pathway to where most people want to go, and there's no pathway for another party to exist politically in a country, when you don't have humanities. And liberal arts to put us in touch with history. You know. I don't mean history like the textbook history. I mean. Our own cultural history. And tradition. That makes these things that I think we see as modern.
给你没有途径去大多数人想去的地方，并且在一个国家里没有另一个政党在政治上存在的途径，当你没有人文科学时。和文科让我们接触历史。你知道。我不是指像教科书历史那样的历史。我是指。我们自己的文化历史。和传统。这使得这些我认为我们视为现代的东西。
Inventions or modern realities. It cuts them off from us. We're really seeing their ancient nature or the archetypal nature of how they work. Again, that psychology is real, you know? I think, you know, James Hillman, the psychologist, the Indian psychologist, has this, that acorn theory about how like you may feel crazy because you're an acorn that got thrown into a sunflower field, but you were just an acorn. Like you were born with this inner spark that you have to actualize. And we all have that. And when you are not seeing a way to become what you were supposed to be,
发明或现代现实。它把它们从我们身边切断了。我们实际上是在看到它们古老的本质或它们运作方式的原型本质。同样，心理学是真实的，你知道？我想，你知道，詹姆斯·希尔曼（James Hillman），心理学家，印度心理学家，有这个，那个橡子理论，关于你可能觉得疯狂，因为你是一颗被扔进向日葵田的橡子，但你只是一颗橡子。就像你带着这种你必须实现的内在火花出生一样。我们都有那个。当你没有看到一种方式成为你本应成为的样子时，
then just our psychology is going to make us deflect, defer, or project that pathway to actualization onto shortcuts. And those shortcuts are going to be cults of conspiracy theories that are going to hurt us and hurt people around us. And unless you fix the systemic problem that is always going to be exploiting and enabling these things to exist, and then scapegoating them a lot of the time, pretending that, well, these people are just crazy. Well, those people are just stupid. Instead instead of like our world doesn't work and it should work better. You know, they're, they're a deflection away from systemic problems in a way that I don't think is good. And will these problems always be around? Yes. You know, have they always been around? Yes. notice that the system is broken and that people who want to grow and change are being cut off from authentic pathways to actualization when these things increase in frequency, intensity, and duration? Yes. Also, we can notice that. Thank you. Succes! Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那么我们的心理只会让我们偏转、推迟或将那种实现途径投射到捷径上。而那些捷径将是会伤害我们和伤害我们周围人的邪教或阴谋论。除非你解决总是会剥削和使这些事情存在，然后很多时候把它们当作替罪羊的系统性问题，假装，好吧，这些人只是疯了。好吧，那些人只是愚蠢。而不是像我们的世界不运作，它应该运作得更好。你知道，它们，它们是对系统性问题的偏转，以一种我认为不好的方式。这些问题会一直存在吗？是的。你知道，它们一直存在吗？是的。注意到系统坏了，想要成长和改变的人被切断了通往实现的真实途径，当这些事情在频率、强度和持续时间上增加时？是的。此外，我们可以注意到这一点。谢谢。成功！谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。